good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Friday oh my God
Friday Friday gonna get down on Friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend Friday Friday getting
down from Friday wasn't she just in the
news didn't something happen to her
Rebecca Black yeah are you keeping up
with pop culture again Ben I'm just like
I remember seeing her name and it was
negative oh no
well that's okay because Ben is here
today which is so exciting if you're
watching on YouTube
there's kind of like something crazy
happening like we added a second camera
we're trying something new so if you
hate it let us know if you'd like it let
us know and if it sucks we'll never do
it again but we got another camera we
got new curtains I wanted to you know
shake up the studio and Jackie's not
here to tell me no so I'm doing what I
want it's Anarchy over here at the toast
Jackie is not available today but her
losses are gain because Ben
then
then I'm just saying it really is her
losses our game yeah I'm so viral the
second that you clip this and it goes on
Tick Tock like if you look at all of
your tick tocks yeah the ones with me in
it
to the Moon actually the ones with
Jackie in it like always go to the moon
but you two for sure for sure to the
moon what do you think it is about you
that has that Viral quality
I don't know what an interesting
question I think that maybe I just bring
out a different side of you you
definitely bring out like a more
um
what is the word
they bring out like a more
um sassy side of me yeah yeah yeah and I
definitely get like a little more
stressed when we podcast together
because I'm doing stories and I'm doing
ads and I'm just like you let me take
the load off give me the give me the
iPad no no I could no that would make me
more stress it would yeah and it must be
so fun for you like you just get to sit
and chat and be like the funny guy
everybody loves totally but like I can
take the stress off I can do it no you
can't no but it's okay I can oh my God
he's been podcasting for what a month
and he thinks he could do my job by the
way a month literally we're at the
University of Miami where you're doing a
wonderful speaking gig you and Jackie
she turns to the audience and says yeah
Ben's being so great good guys 14
episodes
31. sorry I do one month six months I
did reference the good guys in our panel
um because we're always talking about
how you know people are always asking
like how do we
start a podcast and what are your
biggest tips and I think a lot of people
say like if you haven't started a
podcast you're too late it's too late
for you and I think the good guys are a
great example that it's not too late if
you have quality content you guys in the
beginning you've had some audio issues
you worked through them then you got
your videos up so if you have quality
audio quality video and quality guys
it's not too late and that was I know
you're focusing on the part the way I
said you only had 14 episodes and you
actually have 30. sorry I don't count
every day but it was a compliment or
listen or watch excuse me I'm your
number one fan
are you up to date uh no what was the
most recent episode I definitely missed
it because I know you told that story
about
um
when you were a teenager and you watched
porn with a friend and you ran home and
told your mom yeah that was very very
it's a great great story yeah check out
good guys in case you wanna okay let's
get some good guys tea because what was
it yesterday or no two days ago you were
here in our studio recording a remote
episode with Josh with a very premium
guest who I'm a really big fan of good
guys is getting premium guests because
Josh is just a celebrity I know it's
like crazy how famous he is yeah he's so
famous and all of his friends are just
famous friends so tell everyone who your
guest was so Tana Mojo was just on the
show well she's amazing uh she was just
like really smart and like uh an
entrepreneur Mogul like the way that she
has navigated this like only fans
business like you'll hear about it more
in the podcast but she owns her own only
fans agency
yeah it's amazing it's really smart it's
amazing she's starting a weed company
starting a weed company uh and she's
just a very very interesting gal yeah
and we really enjoyed talking to her
also just like quick spoiler we like
just amazing guests can I talk about
some of the other guests coming up
coming up let's tease one at a time I
think it's good like let's get everyone
excited about Tana
have to give one more no but I already
started talking about it wait I can't
even remember I know you told me
yesterday don't say it don't say it
don't say it you told me yesterday my
Josh got blank for Good Guys oh I'm not
going to talk about that one oh okay
fine there's a lot of them no don't okay
fine give one more one more John Stamos
oh of course because Josh and John
Stamos are like best friends everywhere
you look yeah from where do you ever do
you ever feel fomo since like a lot of
times you live in New York and the
guests sometimes you're in LA to record
with them but sometimes you're remote
and then do you feel like left out of
the conversation no because I make sure
to insert myself in the conversation
love that for you pound but uh I do wish
that we could be in person together
doing it every day it's just so much
easier yeah because it's like like this
is so easy I know I'd say you get about
50 of your episodes in together which is
good yeah because I'm constantly
traveling to California God forbid Josh
comes here totally is that like a get
off your keister is that like a point of
contention in your relationship no
because like he gets tana and John
Stamos no totally and the dear media
studios are like so pretty they always
look so good the episodes amazing yeah
amazing but like nothing beats this
studio actually like a lot of things
beat the studio we're a little peacocked
over here
um I think this is amazing
I'm like very nervous about like our new
camera our new setup we did get new
curtains thanks for noticing um so do
the curtains match the drapes don't be
disgusting this is a family show you
could you could spew discussing things
like that on your own show good guys
over here we are a family show we have a
lot of kids who watch with their mothers
this is a nice show Even though today we
got like a crazy vaginal story that I
can't wait to tell you about
by the way apologies if I sound like I'm
sick uh it's just my Augmentin just
coming back up the throat you know I had
a sinus infection now the sinus
infection seems to be cured but I just
gotta say modern medicine you take too
much of it all of a sudden it makes you
more sick that's true antibiotics what's
it called rebound I don't know the
rebound whenever anyone I know is taking
Amoxicillin I share with them a story
that nobody listens to me and you have
to learn the hard way it's the same with
like the notovirus yeah when you are
taking a lot of amoxicillin and you're
sick and you're not eating like you will
have the craziest diarrhea and stomach
pains unless you're taking a probiotic
so whenever anyone I know is taking
Amoxicillin I tell them get a probiotic
and people don't listen to me you didn't
listen speaking of diarrhea should we
talk about last night yeah it's not
about us yeah that was just like oh my
God so uh we literally woke up at we
went to bed early like 11 we woke up at
like one one a.m to a crying sound and
it was Bruno and Bruno had the craziest
smelliest most liquidy diarrhea all over
our carpet like my God Bruno you could
have done on the hard way to throw it
away we threw it we literally threw our
carpet away in the middle of the night
and I was torn between feeling bad for
him and wanting to kill him I felt very
bad for him because any
diarrhea that smells like that like oh
that's not I always think people are so
dramatic people always say oh my oh my
God oh my God I'm gonna throw up shut up
that was you no I know but like shut up
you're not gonna throw up like nine
times out of ten every single time I've
heard
so dramatic this oh my God I was gonna
throw up like this was the simelius you
know what I think you might feel
differently once you start changing
diapers like I have I've changed Harry's
diaper many times Michaela I've changed
all the kids diapers and every now and
then the kid eats something that blows
it up and it is so
putrid and you're so close to it because
the baby's up on a changing table it
will change your stance on this it will
is there something that we can invent
masks the smell or is it like just like
a clip or it's called breathing through
your mouth nah yeah it's very effective
there's got to be something when you go
into like a men's room in like a kind of
gross public maybe like a bar do you
breathe through your nose
I like to ask really kind of I mean and
thought-provoking questions here at the
toast I mean yeah
unless it smells like then I try
not to no you breathe through your mouth
I always breathe through my nose
oh so you obviously haven't mastered the
task
no that's a breathing through your mouth
breathing through your mouth is just
like
whenever I go into I feel like everyone
whenever you go into a public restroom
that's like smelly you can get away
without smelling it in through the nose
out through the mouth well so you
haven't Mass you haven't
mastered the task of breathing through
your mouth that's what you should have
been doing last night it's possible so
are you breathing in through your nose
the whole time when you were wiping up
the no I was not breathing at all I
would wipe up the
I would exhale I would take a towel
smell into the towel get a deep breath
go back to the one thing about us
is that when we're podcasting get
together like we will end up talking
about it's me I know but then
sometimes I think like sometimes with
Jackie like I'm always talking about
poop like maybe it's us Jackie hates
when we talk about poop sorry sorry
she's not here to yell at us sorry
what do you call duty like what's your
go-to word poo doody poop
um for humans it's
for children it's numero dos for dogs
it's number two right what did I say the
amazing so you're bilingual yeah what do
I say oats you're so bright yeah number
two numero dose
ubiquitously
use the word Duty
I use the word dump Duty's such an
underrated word it's good I also feel
like how you refer to
we have to stop talking about I'm
sorry but I just want to say like how
you refer to poo is really indicative of
like how you were raised because I feel
like every family like what did your mom
used to say number two number two okay
so we grew up in a duty household and
that's why I always say Duty no I always
say like I have to go make a duty no
okay I'm changing the subject I'm
changing the subject what's new with you
um what's new with me just getting over
this cold being a mogul trying to be a
mogul it's day three of no bread for
Passover by the way I hope everyone had
an amazing Passover I'm definitely
struggling and this is more than I've
struggled or I usually struggle like day
four or five I'm like you know are you
struggling oh my God I'm so hungry and
like nothing more food I know but like
what I can't eat any of the things that
I love that's the thing matzah Pizza
which Ben makes like Italiano it's so
good is the only thing getting me
through but like my favorite food's
Bagels pasta pizza
you can do all those things with matzah
ugh
by the way
you love grilled chicken you can still
eat it you love grilled salmon sort of
you could still eat it you love it
grilled chicken caesar salads you could
still eat it the hard part for me to be
honest is the rice because like I can't
have rice and yes I love grilled chicken
but you know what I really love grilled
chicken and rice you could have rice no
okay so this is actually like a little
kind of deep Jewish history lesson rice
and corn and barley are called kineot
and technically they're not like
leavened but there's two different kinds
of juice or either spartic or ashkenaz
ashkenaz Jews hail from more like
Eastern Europe where asphardic Jews hail
more from like Middle East to Arab
um Arab lands like Morocco Syria so um
we are not of that descent but Sephardic
Jews who are of that more Middle Eastern
descent they can have kineotes so they
don't even feel it they're over here
having rice and sushi sushi and we're
over here eating matzah pizza and I just
want to say it's not fair and I'm
thinking about doing like ancestry.com
just to find like a deep dark spartic
relative because I think I'm going to
start converting to spartism you could
do it anyways you can eat rice I'm not
gonna lie isn't it just like the isn't
it just the rabbis at this point telling
us what we can and can't eat but at the
base of it it's just
no leaven bread right and then we added
all these little things to make it more
complicated the story of Passover is you
know our people were slaves in Egypt for
400 years and then Moses was like I'm
taking you guys out of here let my
people go so we were rushing to get out
rushing away and we were trying to make
some snacks for the road because you
know we're Jewish and we were trying to
make bread but we had no time the people
were coming for us so we just grabbed
the bread before it could love it in the
oven and it was kind of like this nasty
consistency it hadn't risen so it was
like a cracker
um and that's what Matt says it's
unleavened bread and
that's really what we're supposed to
survive on and so I understand why we
can't eat leavened bread to commemorate
what our people went through but like
our people didn't even have rice like
why the did you have to bring that
up rice wasn't even being spoken about
because this is the ashkenaz rabbis
taking it too far I think they wanted to
make it they want to make it harder for
us so we can really feel the pain of our
people and I I respect that I do it's
just it's really hard then why isn't
there a fast
good question
such a Jewish history lesson of the day
when Moses was in Egypt land let my
people go it's also shocking to me how
few people who aren't Jewish haven't
seen the film The Prince of Egypt it's
so breathtaking it's so moving and it
features one of the most iconic moments
in pop culture history a Duo a duet
between Mariah Carey and Whitney Houston
what's that song I forget can you look
it up what did they sing um what's the
song uh it's in the end I think maybe
they played in the credits it's really
beautiful it's deeply moving and I think
um
you will when you believe and Pentatonix
actually has a cover and you know I like
kind of hate Pentatonix they have a
cover that is so beautiful it will move
you to tears I think Aaron Morris is on
it too so that's just like a fun fact
about you know the film like if you
haven't seen it are there people that
haven't seen a Rugrats Passover
I think that that's just like a classic
like the kids saw it there are people
that was a kind of an amazing thing that
Rugrats did for us unbelievable Rugrats
was such a popular show at the time
everyone was watching it from all
different backgrounds and they did a big
special explaining Passover for kids and
it was so cool for us so cool and I just
want to say thanks yeah thank you thank
you Rugrats I felt seen me too me too
thank you Rugrats really seen thank you
um we have great stories today actually
because we haven't done a show since you
and I did one on Tuesday Tuesday so we
have a lot to catch up on and there's a
big story that I'm actually going to
start with because I know how much it
means to you yeah so I think it's time
what are the past five stories that you
need to know before you take a bite out
of your morning tell us oh by the way I
get it I know morning toes bite that's
why you eliminated on Tuesday beat the
crunch needs to come back how about
we'll keep it a tradition that whenever
you're here and because you're always so
busy you have like so many meetings we
have to record so early today
um it kind of is morning whenever you're
here we'll do it okay fine so here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning
just
I don't know that was tight vote I don't
know vote in the comments today's
episode is brought to you
God by catch 2023 is the year of good
feel good do good be good to yourself
and Kitsch makes feeling good with
simple with luxurious game changing
Essentials that beauty enthusiasts swear
by so whatever your budget whatever your
skin type or hair type kitchen believes
that you deserve little indulgences at
affordable prices morning noon and night
so a lot of the kitchen best sellers
include their satin pillowcases caps and
eye mask which is great for your skin
and hair while you sleep if you wake up
with like lines on your face or you wake
up with A Rat's Nest even though you
have a blowout from the night before try
switching to a satin pillowcase it will
change your life
um the the kitchen is vegan and cruelty
free they're so good for your hair and
skin while you sleep they also have
shampoo and conditioner bars yeah bars
which is a part of their bottle free
Beauty which is a great way to help the
environment but also keep your hair
clean so important and they're really
famous for their heatless satin curling
rollers so you can say goodbye to heat
damage and goodbye to your really
expensive curlers because you can now
get gorgeous curls for a fraction of the
price they're just 18 they also have
quick dry hair towels which are fabulous
classic hair ties scrunchies and so much
more I have so many of the kids products
the sound satin pillowcase is fabulous
um I think this morning I was actually
wearing one of their
um scrunchies everything and anything
you need for hair and skin check out
catch right now kitchen's offering you
30 off your entire order at mykitch.com
toast that's right 30 off anything and
everything at my kitchen which is
spelled
m-y-k-i-t-s-c-h.com slash toast that's
mykitch.com toast for 30 off your order
today's episode is also brought to you
by Noom Trends and fads come and go
especially when it comes to health and
wellness Noom is not a fad they use
psychology not Trends to help you make
intentional and sustainable choices that
are aligned with your values and your
weight loss goals so whatever your
weight loss goals maybe I know for me
like a huge goal was just to feel better
not so much about the scale even though
that's some people's goal for me it
wasn't me I was getting really fatigued
getting bad headaches and so just like
being more conscious about what I put in
my body was really helpful for me um but
whatever
whatever your reasoning is Noom is a
great psychology-based approach they
Empower you to build more sustainable
habits and behaviors because so much
about diet and what you put in your body
is psychological with uh the program
that helps you understand the science
behind your eating choices and why you
have cravings everyone's journey is
different so your daily lessons are
personalized to you and your goals
um they believe in nourishing instead of
restricting so whatever your goals are
their flexible program focuses on
progress instead of perfection if you
have a bad day if you need to have a bad
day Noom is totally cool with that don't
have to get off track just because of
one bad day
first time numerous lose an average of
15 pounds after being active on the
program for 16 weeks and 95 percent of
consumers say that Noom is a good
long-term solution what I really like
about Numa is their food database so if
you want to just keep track of what
you're eating they have a really
expansive database that has pretty much
everything that you could think of and
it's really
um
on point so stop chasing Health Trends
and build sustainable healthy habits
with new psychology-based approach sign
up for your trial today at noon.com
toast that's
n-o-o-m.com toast to sign up for your
trial today check out noom's first book
the new mindset a deep dive into the
psychology of behavior change available
to buy now wherever books are sold all
right are you ready for our first story
that is really going to make you wet
your pants please I'll give you I'll
give you a clue okay
oh wait hang on didn't we say like 10
minutes ago when I said something this
is a family-friendly show but now I'm
wetting my pants over a story what's
wrong with wetting your pants it's a
family-friendly show who what's their
pants more than kids
gotcha you thought I said CREAM your
pants which I didn't did okay here's a
clue for our first story ready yeah
I don't know why I'm like floating on
just be quiet
um
what do you think you'll be just fine
without me but you're mine you think you
can kick me out of the band and then
Zach you come in with the space space
well there's just one problem there the
band is mine how can you kick me out of
what is mine all right we have some
School of Rock news and I don't think
there is a show on the internet that is
more obsessed with School of Rock than
we are
obsessed and like have we spoken about
the time that we saw it in theaters for
my friend lior's birthday that was I
actually
have but just
do you have it because you know my
memory is not the best during covid
people did not take advantage enough of
the fact that you could rent out an
entire movie theater for
somewhere between 90. it was 99 99 for
an old movie or 199 for a new one oh
yeah but we didn't have to see a new
movie you could literally choose a film
because most theaters wouldn't open up
to like sell individual seats but if you
were a party you could literally rent a
theater for 99 and 30 people it wasn't
the height of Kobe but it was still very
much like things were a little murky and
your friend Leo rented a movie theater
for his birthday and chose School of
Rock to watch everybody brought we
brought like alcohol snacks I we brought
the tailors it was like a free-for-all
because there was uh such a big theater
and there was only like 15 of us we
brought the tailors we like packed a
cooler it was so much fun and he that
was probably one of the better birthdays
in kovid so fun yeah three dollars a
person three bucks well it's not three
dollars a person why 30 people no I know
but Elliott I mean not Elliot Leo just
paid the 99 right yeah but I'm just
posting I'm just simply sharing and the
concession stand was open yeah it was
which which hike up the price it did it
was so worth it okay I actually remember
that I remember that thinking wow this
is such a great like easy cheap fun
birthday get to the concession stand I
spent 200 I know but that's you yeah it
is me but I think it's everyone no but I
have problems with that you end up
buying snacks for people you haven't no
that's not your problem you're not too
much generous no you over ordered that
no no but lifelong problems it's both
problems I over order for myself but I'm
also far too generous with the snacks I
will give you an example I spoke about
this on good guys but it was recently in
the Bahamas we spoke about wait can I
tell you say one thing just as like kind
of a podcast mentor to you yeah since
you're you know you're so frequently on
the toast especially this last couple
weeks you've just been on a lot and you
have good guys I think it's important
that you not be so repetitive because a
lot of people who listen to this listen
to good guys so I just that was just
like my piece of advice like before you
repeat something make sure it's worth
that so what should I do
human life
you're so funny continue
I'll say it quickly
Bahamas airport really hungover
foot long Quiznos
egg and cheese and I just wanted you
told the story on the toast too I did
yeah
finish it
no I can't no finish it
whatever I got a lot of Starbucks snacks
for people move on okay hahaha
I told this story on the toast you did
it might have been on patreon but you've
told you've told it because I heard it I
didn't tell it on the toast yeah you did
I remember we were sitting in Jackie's
Studio when I heard the story patreon
yeah
um okay ready for this story about uh
Jack Black yes Jack Black has confirmed
in a recent interview with Entertainment
Tonight that he is planning to reunite
with his younger School of Rock co-stars
later this year to celebrate the 20th
anniversary of the comedy's release
various cast members have reunited over
the years but it sounds like Jack Black
is plotting an epic reunion to celebrate
20 years of School of Rock here's what
he said all those kids did this they
were 10 years old when we made that
movie and now they're all like 30. we're
gonna get together and have a 20 year
anniversary we like to jam I'm looking
forward to seeing all the grown-ups from
School of Rock he added that he will 100
use social media to upload photos and
videos for the oh from the upcoming
reunion
um School of Rock
directed by Richard link later and
written by the White Lotus oh I didn't
realize it was written by Ned schneibly
I did oh I just thought he said such an
interesting career and you know he's a
creator of a White Lotus I had no idea
you want to hear something crazy Ned
schnevely was in school of rock and I
think he had like a kind of you know not
not exciting but like you know decent
career but things tapered off for him
and he went on Survivor that show and he
had this cult following from the show he
had like an epic season I've never
watched it but I know it's like a
historic season and he was like a real
star in it and he does huge following
from Survivor that really helped him get
White Lotus off the ground and now he's
literally the darling of Hollywood
everyone wants to be in next season of
White Lotus and I for I didn't even know
that he wrote School of Rock I mean it
makes sense he's obviously like a
talented like Creator and writer and
more than just being an actor yeah and
Ned schneem blue is a terrible character
I know it was crazy that he wrote this
amazing movie and cast himself as the
most annoying human being on the planet
actually sorry Sarah Silverman was the
worst in that movie I don't know at
least Sarah said Silverman stood for
something like he stood for being
annoying as hell she was a narc but like
at least she had you know principles
that she stuck to negatively was so
wishy-washy spineless who is the teacher
again Joan Cusack amazing She's Gotta Be
in the reunion I love Joan Cusack we
were just talking about her the other
day on the toes like where is she what's
she up to I'm just saying we have a
direct in here because Josh and Miranda
Cosgrove are friends you have to get
Miranda cosgor on the podcast after she
does the reunion not before no we're
doing it before because of iCarly oh
yeah her and Josh are both on the iCarly
reboot spoiler alert
um okay well it sounds like this reunion
is not gonna be like a production it's
going to be like an actual like high
school reunion like everyone getting
back together it has to be a production
no he says like I will definitely um
share on social media I know but now
that
now there's so much hype around it
somebody's gonna come in and he will
upload photos and videos from the
upcoming reunion it sounds like it's
just like a get-together probably at his
house
I know I love Jack Black he's probably
like one of the best celebrities he's
the best like I feel like there are
people who are so universally famous and
so down to Earth but also like probably
the biggest like I would consider like
one of the greats right now of like
Dwayne Johnson yeah because he's in a
lot of kids content so like everybody
loves him and I think I would put Jack
Black on that level too he's the best I
love the best multi-talented yeah you
know you guys share something in common
both singers and Comics yeah Tenacious D
he's a big singer you don't know
Tenacious D his band no oh my God are
you even a Jack Black then not as big as
you oh my God calm down he literally is
a band
called Tenacious D yeah and there's a
movie Tenacious D really uh-huh
it's like a whole musical movie that but
see that's what's you're right like
about Jack Black like the fact that he's
in School of Rock which is one of the
greatest comedies of our time and he's
like this illustrious comedy career but
he also like tugged at the heartstrings
in the holiday which is a cult classic
in the rom-com genre um Shallow Hal
shallow shallow hell we just quote
Shallow Hal every day hey now she's
getting into my Clams Casino that would
be so good iconic iconic yeah Costanza's
in it Tony Robbins is in it Gwyneth
Paltrow of course my queen that movie
could never get made today because it's
definitely problematic but I choose not
to care or see it why is it more
problematic Than Love is Blind because
Love is Blind is not blind when you
don't cast one fat person I've been
saying that for years it won't be
interesting like I think the first
season had like really interesting
conversations especially with Lauren and
what is his name Lauren and blank
Hamilton who are still married because
they were talking about how he was white
she was black what would her family
think about that would have like it
presented an actual obstacle for them
her dad was very trepidatious like it
was an actual obstacle
no no when you just cast like average
looking people who all look the same
like it's not interesting I would have
found I agree I want a fat person in
there I cannot wait for the School of
Rock reunion although it does it is like
a little bit of a misleading headline
it's not like a Friends reunion that was
a great reunion I needed taped I needed
taped as well should we just sneak in
totally it'll it'll be at probably
Jack's house because he's like probably
so rich yeah I could go to Jax I mean
there's so many underrated stars in
there Miranda Cosgrove Joan Cusack
negative Sarah Silverman I cannot wait
any other underrated story oh very sad
though you know recently um Freddy the
drummer he passed away
did hear that yeah that's really sad so
hopefully they'll like you know
commemorate him or something that he was
great yeah just such a good movie
unbelievable
um great for kids and parents I agree I
agree it's the type of movie that
actually gets better the older you get
whereas a lot of things we like
romanticize in our heads and then we
re-watch it as adults we're like that
really wasn't that good but School of
Rock stands the test of time it actually
gets better the older you get same with
High School Musical
debatable no you're wrong you don't give
it a chance
debatable no the originals are great
what do you mean the originals that's
what I'm talking about no like you watch
like all this crap like the the new
version okay I haven't watched that in
years I'm talking about High School
Musical one two and three one is good
three is the best movie you'll ever see
in your life I just
I want the rest of my life to feel just
like a high school music
I know that scene gives you Goosebumps I
just like I really do want the rest of
my life to feel like a high school
musical
don't you deep yeah everyone should
exactly
um okay ready for our next story yes a
little bit more potential not really
reunion news apparently according to
Daily Mail Liam Payne is desperate for a
One Direction reunion to relaunch his
career and he's trying to get in contact
with his former bandmates so Liam Payne
is reportedly desperate for a One
Direction reunion the pop star 29 who
was in the group with Niall Horan Harry
Styles Louis Tomlinson and Zayn Malik
has been trying to get into contact with
his former bandmates it comes after Liam
recently reunited with Louis at the
premiere of his documentary which was
called all of these voices in London The
Source said that Liam is desperate
desperate to get back on the road with
the boys his solo career hasn't remained
as successful as he hoped it would and
work has become stagnant for him in
contrast he can see how well Harry is
doing and he'd love that level of
stardom for himself
um okay
yeah you know what I like I'd like the
level of stardom that Amy Schumer has
like we don't want things Liam get in
line get to work
you're far closer to Schumer in my
opinion than Liam is to Harris such a
lie and so nice thank you I completely
forgot that Liam even existed I know
it's like when if you would have asked
me I'm always saying if you if you would
have asked me when the boys broke up
like who would have the biggest career I
would have said Harry that was like it
was always it was never a question he
really was the biggest star and he was
so beloved by the audience
but if you would have asked me like who
would be struggling this much I would
not have said Liam he was like at least
vocally top three he was a favorite
I wouldn't be shocked if you told me
that Niall Horan would be having the
second best career second to Harry I
just didn't pan out how I thought it
would Niall Horan is killing it killing
it we were watching the Masters
yesterday he was like on like talking
about the Masters oh yeah he's a big
golfer how he like shot an 81 at Augusta
which I'm gonna need to see like some
proof well he's Irish it's a hard Golf
Course isn't um golf like a huge thing
in Ireland yeah but it's also a huge
thing in the United States and shooting
in 81 in Augusta is just like so good
such a hard course yeah and they like
got it ready for the Masters so the
course is playing Masters level yeah
regardless he must be amazing he must be
amazing or he must be a liar or he's a
liar yeah
um I'm gonna lean on amazing one like
fun fact about Ben and I that definitely
makes me feel like we're better than
other people is that we had the
opportunity to see One Direction live at
MetLife and now Not only was it
incredible they also were opened the
opening act was five seconds of summer
and we weren't even five seconds of
summer crazy fans yet but we went for
the opener and I think that really
ignited our love it did and then we
started to follow them around to like
weird venues across this country no Five
Seconds of Summer like
what their manager did to that band I
agree I will never ever forgive it they
had a chance to be the pop punk gen Z
phenoms bring back like they could be
blink 182. instead they went down this
like weird road with like trying to be
alternative trying to be mainstream no
you don't have to be mainstream when
you're awesome at something let me say
how I actually don't think it was a
management issue I think like a they
went through like a really bad Scandal
where that that one of the members
Michael
um was like had really kind of
disgusting and terrible accusations
against him about how he treated
underage fans like very inappropriately
so that definitely rocks the boat and
they were very much like doing what they
wanted to be doing like any music they
were putting out like was very much a
band's decision and they were young and
they were growing up and they were like
going through different phases so I
think they started to like put out music
that wasn't like but it was still really
good I was just about to say so you
follow me
young blood was the problem but that was
their biggest song No their biggest song
was you look so perfect standing there
in my American Apparel underwear yeah
like or black heart because I've got a
jet black heart and there's a hurricane
underneath it we gotta rock out with our
outside yeah we do we do we went
to Jones Beach I got Claudia third row
this was probably like six years ago it
was the only guy in the entire Arena
only guy we were the only adults it was
literally a concert for 13 year olds and
that reason we got third rows because
the tickets were like 25 it was so good
it was so good we were rocking out so
hard with like all these kids around us
yeah unbelievable and I think that's
also where they struggled they had this
like teeny bopper fan base great grow up
with them who just like weren't into it
for much longer they would but because
they they changed there too it's also
important to know they're an Australian
band so their success in America was
like never that's not their main beat
really yeah
so interesting I know like when they do
tours they usually do Europe like maybe
America is an afterthought they're not
like an America first band Australia is
so interesting I know I'd love to go
it's just so far but like no I can't do
it so many like so much amazing
goes on in Australia I mean the toast is
huge in Australia Australia toaster show
yourselves Aussie Aussie Aussie Jose and
have you ever seen the movie already
oh I don't know
I don't know if that has to do with
Australia like whenever I try to do an
Australian accent it turns Russian Troy
good day mate how you doing
can you do it good day mate that was
pretty good yeah okay now you're going
into like g'day like Slovenian
g'day mate how you doing
now you're just Southern
the only way that I know how to do it is
that our friend is Australian and she
calls me Bane yeah no she's not
Australian she's from New Zealand sorry
and she's a toaster shout out Maya by
the way Australia New Zealand it's very
offensive to do not say that really very
problematic actually I guess it's like
somebody saying oh America Canada and by
the way we don't no no we're huge in
Canada don't say it either no by the way
I love Canada I can't wait to return
Viva Canada I love Canadians too
buffer Canada
wow okay on let me say watch today's
episode you know I'm not you um
what's the word I'm looking for by the
way the Canadians will respect why I
don't like him okay I don't like Canada
because every single day I get probably
200 DMS bring Spirit Society to Canada
and I want you to know that your
government makes it impossible for
anybody to bring beverages to Canada
which is why you have none of your
favorite drinks yeah none of them and if
you do have them they're double the
price because your government is the
mafia on beverage no by the way that's a
fair critique but Canadians love them
Natalie oh our friend Natalie is a
Montreal Montreal no and like Canada's
so Jewish we love the best the best
Canadians come over here all the time
we're like they're like vacation
destination it must be so fun to like
have like a like a nearby country be
America even though we have like our
problems and stuff but like it's so lit
it is lit actually Canada is pretty lit
too like Montreal's so fun no and I
haven't seen enough I want to go to
Vancouver I hear Vancouver you have I
have been did you have a show in
Vancouver wow that's pretty cool yeah it
didn't sell well so I didn't return for
analog sorry yeah but like we'll we'll
find another place but it's just
interesting like another place in Canada
to try next yeah there's very beautiful
parts of Canada yeah Vancouver is
closest to Seattle yes I drove from
Seattle or maybe it was Portland I
forget no Seattle two it was three hours
cool yeah very cool what were we talking
about we were talking about
let's go backwards because that was five
seconds of summer oh One Direction Liam
Payne yeah so he wants the band to get
back together and of course he does and
just a reminder Liam Payne wants to be
as famous as Harry Styles that's what we
were talking about yeah and that's like
makes him so different like nobody wants
that yeah I mean it's definitely tough
to like have been at that level of Fame
with five of your like friends and to to
year after year like kind of become more
forgotten and not only that out of all
of them like Liam's solo career has
become kind of like a meme on the
internet especially tick tock
there's like all these videos of him
that went viral like doing meet and
greets like it was he he kind of got
power deed and his solo career is very
much like become a joke which is tough
when you see how her style is winning
Grammy for album of the year was it
Simon Hawk who put them all together
Simon Huck I'm cracking up Simon Cowell
yes Simon Huck Simon you were just on my
brain yeah Simon Powell who put them all
together Simon Powell yes towel
Simon Cowell yes it was X Factor UK do
you think he still gets like some money
from them from One Direction yes and
that was a part of like why they were so
unhappy that happens a lot I think
people got hands in their pockets no
it's like when you get famous on a show
like that they when you sign up like you
are agreeing to like these crazy record
deal contracts that if you get a record
deal after that's what I think um broke
them up no no that's what I think
Phillip Phillips who had like the number
one song for a really long time after he
won American Idol home what Simon hugs
Simon Powell yeah I was trying to make a
plane but like whatever
um that you get stuck in like really bad
contracts after you're on those shows
certainly yeah but they're not still I
mean even though I do think Simon Cowell
makes residuals off of One Direction's
catalog of music Still for sure
what a Visionary though yeah see five
individuals push them together Simon
Cowell is is who he is for a reason he
is who he is
um before we continue with the rest of
the stories let me let everyone know
that today's episode is brought to you
by the perfect bar Spring cleaning your
fridge should be fun right so why not
toss out those Dusty condiments and
replace the space with a lineup of fresh
from the fridge protein bars delicious
and nutritious perfect bar has your
fridge and snacking needs covered this
spring season made with freshly ground
nut butter organic honey and 20 organic
superfoods perfect bar has a variety of
products like protein bars little snack
size bars that are also good and good
for you you'll be sure to find something
you love of personal favorite here at
the toast is the chocolate chip cookie
dough it is so delicious and because
they're made with whole food ingredients
that contain no artificial preservatives
the perfect bars are stored in the
fridge that means when you pull it out
like that outer shell of chocolate is it
has a nice little crunch to it and the
inside because it's made with such
natural fresh ingredients is really
doughy and it's so good they make um
a snack size too now which is uh packed
with up to six six grams of proteins and
150 calories a little goes a long way so
grab one after a workout or for a quick
bite while you're out shopping if you
aren't already convinced there are also
non-GMO project verified they're
gluten-free soy free kosher and low GI
perfect bar knows that it'll be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text and upload a picture of your
receipt from your local grocery store
and they will reimburse you for the cost
of one bar it'll go directly into your
PayPal or venmo account all you have to
do is go to perfect snacks.com toast to
get a free perfect bar today that's
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today happy snacking and
happy free snacking today's episode is
brought to you by modern fertility for a
lot of us the start of a year can feel
like the right time to schedule doctor's
appointments and check in with where
you're at health-wise but what about
your reproductive Health we've always
been a big fan of planning ahead
scheduling trips months in advance
plotting our next career moves figuring
out what we're doing for dinner while
we're still eating lunch but if you've
never thought about planning for kids
modern fertility could be a great asset
for you modern fertility was created as
an easy and affordable way to test your
fertility hormones at home with a simple
finger prick mail it in with a prepaid
label and you'll get a personalized
result within six business dates you
will get insight into your hormone
levels like your ovarian reserve AKA if
you have more or fewer eggs than the
average woman your age you'll also get
other important factors that can impact
your fertility the results go deep into
what every hormone means and you can
also download the results to review with
your doctor for next steps traditional
hormone testing at a fertility clinic
can cost over six hundred dollars but
modern fertility tests are the same
general set of hormones for only 179
dollars and if you go to
modernfertility.com toast you'll get an
extra 20 off your test plus you'll get
real you can get reimbursed for the test
through your FSA or your HSA so if you
want kids today or maybe one day in the
future clinically sound information
about your body can help you make the
decision that's right for you if you've
done any sort of fertility testing you
know how kind of laborious and expensive
the process can be moderate utility
modern fertility takes so much of the
stress out of fertility testing because
you do it from home it takes six
business days and the results come come
right to your phone right now modern
fertility is offering our listeners 20
off the test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that means
your test will cost 159 which is a
fraction of what it would cost at a
fertility clinic get 20 off your
fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that's
modernfertility.com toast all right are
you ready for our next story Little oh
excuse me no I was literally holding it
in for the ABS Oh no you're welcome Oh
no you're welcome I was holding it in
ready for uh some TV news yes that
really nobody asked for Kourtney
Kardashian and Travis Barker are sharing
an inside look at their new weddings
Hulu special so I know I did say that
weird wedding Hulu special Kourtney
Kardashian and Travis Barker are giving
fans an inside look at their luxurious
Wedding Day in Italy in a new Hulu Hulu
special the streamer announced Tuesday
that the couple were released till death
do us part as an expansion of the famous
families the Kardashians
they said this is our personal archive
footage that we are sharing with the
world
she says it in the trailer as footage of
her and Travis uh that was of footage
taken on their wedding day plays can you
believe we got married three times she
adds referring to their Las Vegas
nuptials their legal Santa Barbara Court
ceremony and then finally their
Portofino bash it's like choosing a
child I can't pick the best one Travis
says so they're basically getting their
own spin-off which is just gonna be like
a limited run about their wedding
um it does feel like
one like who cares
um and two Courtney has spent like the
last three years on the Kardashians
complaining that she doesn't want to
film she wants boundaries especially
like around her family her kids which is
totally respectable
um so this kind of feels like a money
grab it just feels like really kind of
not to sound like such a troll but like
it feels so inauthentic like come on
yeah and they got married so long ago I
feel like so much has happened in the
family since then it just feels kind of
dated too not to be like such a nazare
yeah
I agree that's it that's all you have to
say no I are you like a big Travis
Barker fan yeah I mean I love blink 182.
I I'm just like I'm just here thinking
like they had three weddings and we were
invited to none of them so Joe yeah
three options three opportunities I
really um always forget like there seems
to be a disconnect in my brain that like
Travis Barker who I know now is like
Kardashian who I know is like legendary
as a legendary drummer I forget that he
is also where are you
and I'm so sorry Legend like that
doesn't compute for me in my brain yeah
Legend I don't know why
because because he came into your world
yes as a different type of person what
do you think is the best Blink 182 song
oh that's so tough
oh
maybe first date are they Dear Virginia
who's that
um oh God there's a story at the bar
American high fives
American Hi-Fi she's just the flavor of
the week who sings Dear Maria I mean oh
God no no this is embarrassing okay I
won't tell you let me let me know if you
can think of it
dear Maria count me in there's a story
at the bottom of this bottle and I'm the
pen so much easier to just talk
oh my God you're gonna like you're gonna
be mad at yourself I know just tell me
all time low ah yeah damn it
um but what do you think is the best
blink-182's on I told you what damn it
how does that go and first date how do
those go like you have to sing them pick
up on our very first date is it cool if
I hold your hand is it lame if I didn't
want to dance set the chords back my
stupid hair no no let's go don't wait
yeah this night's almost over
honest let's make this night last
forever forever
it's made and lasts forever in like any
sort of dream world like if you could
have been anything at any time would you
have wanted to be like a singer of like
a punk band in the 90s is that like your
dream life
I think that would have been awesome
like I don't know like you just like the
more you learn the more it was dark yeah
you just like I'd probably be addicted
to drugs yeah it was a very dark time
for a lot of people you like you only
see like the good you don't see like the
the trauma yeah yeah no you're right
that's actually a really good way of
thinking about it because I always say
like I love my job I have the best job
in the world but if I really could be
doing anything like I would really want
to be a singer
you could be a singer like when I see
Taylor Swift like out here doing the
eras tour like I'm so why can't you be a
singer we talk about this all the time I
know I have too many things on my plate
just sing No and the thing is like I
know I have a really good singing voice
like not to be annoying like I know that
I do but I am better
I'm a stronger podcaster and comedian
than I am a singer but you could do both
singing too shout out Allison K sign her
no I know let's do it I know let's do it
you could do it I know if I had your
voice I would do it I can't my voice
stinks wow finally you admitted okay
today's show is a success okay sorry
stinks in the realm of like having a
career singing for the average Joe it's
pretty good it's pretty good yeah it's
pretty good
um so if you could be a lead singer of
any band which one would you what do you
think is like the greatest punk I would
either this isn't Punk but it would
either be the killers yeah Fall Out Boy
or blank those are my three blink you
don't you dropped the 182. yeah
you got a problem with that no no do you
always say Taylor Swift or you just say
Taylor
I pretty much hate Taylor Swift
interesting considering you are
literally the nickname Maestro no okay
you literally call people nicknames okay
wait so so you don't even know them so
if you're someone to nicknames why don't
you just call The Killers the
I'll call him Killers I'll call them
Killers you call them just Killers no I
wouldn't because it doesn't work
um but like The Killers wow yeah I feel
like of those bands I probably would
want to be the lead singer of The
Killers because they have the most
longevity Fallout boys like I don't
think they're together they had a
Resurgence they're together
they're together they're playing at uh
what's that they still tour I think
they're playing it that is it vans come
again there's like a Vans off the wall
like crazy in Vegas oh I don't know
that's so Fall Out Boy yeah they're like
invented bands there's something but
yeah Pete went I mean Legend I'd love to
be Pete ones yeah I mean I wouldn't love
to be Pete Wentz I'd love to be me and
Pete wentz's position yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um okay well Courtney and Travis have a
new show coming and if you care I think
you should watch it yes
um okay so there were some dating rumors
going around that I think you might find
interesting but now both people have
come out and said it's completely not
true Tom Brady and Reese Witherspoon are
not dating and apparently have never
even met
their reps have told page six explicitly
the stars are not romantically involved
nor have they ever met we're told that
rumors that the newly single Duo have
their eyes on each other are completely
false because shortly after Reese split
from her husband of 12 Years last month
an anonymous tip who used an email
address um that's so funny Legally
Blonde at
patriotsbuccaneers.com claimed to do Moi
that an A-list actress who just
announced her divorce is newly dating
this A-list NFL athlete who was also
recently divorced and people put the
clues together so I just think it's
further further it's further proof that
you really need to be cautious about
what you consume in terms of Internet
Anonymous gossip because yesterday Juma
posted a blind That Shook the world down
about Kylie Jenner did you see no said
that Kylie Jenner for a few months has
been dating Timothy chalamet and people
were shook because Timothy chalamet is
so the opposite of her type he's like
very natural we don't know but now
everyone's accepting it is true and
everybody accepted this Tom Brady and
Reese Witherspoon thing is true all you
have to do is read the comments on
Instagram to know if something's true or
not what do you mean like I love when
it's not only page six it's all of like
there are other versions of page six but
you'll go you'll see some crazy headline
and it'll say click the link in BIO to
read the full story but I'll just go to
the comments and somebody will sum it up
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's like so
funny I saw that exact one where it's
like the headline Reese Witherspoon
dates Tom Brady I'm thinking myself what
the hell that's so strange and I go to
the comment section and literally what
what I would have clicked on to read was
there a source close to the two have
said they've never met yeah like how is
that a headline then yeah I actually
feel like that's a good point how like
the Instagram comment section kind of
like with E news or all these
Publications because they say click the
link in our bio to read the full story
and you can get a summary of the story
in the comments you never gotta click it
it actually happened to me yesterday was
a little bit embarrassing there's a an
account that I follow called zire golf
amazing like golf account and there was
this video that was posted out of
context and I should have known better
where it looked like Colin murakawa
amazing amazing golfer amazing I don't
know where he's ranked right now but
amazing uh it looked like he moved his
ball he's on the green and it looked
like he cheated it looked like he
cheated
move
it was a big deal so I commented how can
you be so stupid to do that on
television right like I get when guys
cheat like when nobody's watching but
there was more context yeah oh did they
review the shreds they roasted me but
I'd say 99 of people just liked it
thought it was funny yeah agreed but
then like these like golf books yeah
like nerds below were like did you even
watch he was replacing where it was wind
pushed it legally allowed to move it
back and so it just goes to show that if
you don't have the full story try and
get it before you comment I actually
have a similar embarrassing sports
comment section story when we were um in
the playoffs with the Niners and we were
just like both you know really being
supportive of the 49ers
um they were playing they were playing
the Cowboys and they commented like
who's ready for next week in Dallas like
they posted something on Instagram and I
was like yeah we then boys like that's
what me and Jackie always say like we
them boys we making noise and apparently
that's Dallas that's like the Dallas
slogan who knew that everyone's
commenting get a job that's their
favorite thing oh my God if I never hear
that again it'll be too soon it's so
annoying have any comments on golf if
you're unemployed yeah yeah like oh my
God it's so every time I comment on
pretty much every single Luke Combs
post and he posted the other day like
out of these two songs which should I
send as my next single to country radio
and I commented a third different song I
Want You Found yours to be it commented
what do you know you don't even have a
job no it's so stupid shut up also like
people in person like oh God they'll
come up and they'll say oh congrats on
Spirit society looks like you found a
job oh by the way that is like the go-to
mostly for like older people who think
it's like a really funny original joke
when it comes from like a friend's
parent it doesn't bother me but like
when it comes from somebody who's like
actually like knowledgeable and young
and like understands the landscape it
looks like yeah oh you have a call but
you don't have a job shut up so dumb and
like any press it's like boy with many
jobs oh yeah no whenever you do an
interview so it's like you're actually
pretty busy for a girl with no job it's
enough
it's enough to make me change the handle
enough and it's enough enough
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story that like I said previously
hopefully will make you uh wet your
pants yes it's brought to you by Thrive
Market Thrive Market is our go-to for
all of our grocery and household
essentials and the convenience of
getting it all quickly shipped to our
doorstep is a huge Time Saver so when
you become a Thrive Market member as
Jackie and I both are you can save money
on every single order on average we're
saving over 30 every time so of course
they offer massive savings but they also
have a deals page that changes daily so
you can get cash back on so many Brands
and they have a price match guarantee
they also are a great place just to
discover new brands
um I feel like I used to be very rigid
in terms of what I ate you know I'm very
picky and I just order the same stuff
and I get the same Brands but Thrive
really made me comfortable to like
Branch out and I've fallen in love with
so many brands for food but also for
like house supplies cleaning supplies
things I need for the house things I
need for Theo
um not only describe Market save us
money but they also save us time the
filters on their website there's over 70
are really helpful so whether you're
looking for gluten-free snacks non-toxic
cleaning Essentials you can basically
curate your own shopping experience with
the click of a button so when you join
Thrive Market you are also helping a
family in need because they have a
one-for-one membership matching program
so you join the program and they give a
membership to a family in need which is
fabulous you can feel good about getting
fabulous things for your home helping
others in need and it also is just
shipped right to your door join Thrive
market today and you'll get 30 off your
first order plus a free 60 gift go to
thrivemarket.com the toast for 30 off
your first order plus a free 60 gift
that's
t-h-r-i-v-e-market.com the toast
thrivemarket.com the toast Jackie is
like now at a place where she's getting
like three Thrive Market deliveries a
day because she has like you know
a child to feed and she's his big old
kitchen and every time I'm on FaceTime
with her she is unboxing a new Thrive
Market it's crazy that when you said
cash back my brain immediately when I
hear the word cash now
if you need long-term payments and you
need cash now call JG Wentworth 877 cash
now it's crazy such a good song
Unbelievable for our fifth and final
story I have like a crazy human interest
story that I think you're gonna find
really interesting
interested a gynecologist has revealed
the most shocking thing he's found
inside a vagina
a gynecologist in Honduras was
flabbergasted to discover
a cockroach lurking inside a patient's
vagina
so Dr Marco calix who is an OB GYN based
in
tegucip galpa told the jam press about
the unlikely likely infestation she said
she had something unusual in her vagina
the doctor described how the unnamed
patient who hailed from a rural part of
the country arrived at his Clinic
extremely Restless agitated and sweaty
she explained how she'd been having
trouble sleeping due to something
extremely strange in her vagina a
subsequent inspection revealed the
shocking culprit behind the woman's
discomfort when I introduced the
speculum I could see that it was an
insect in fact I had to take out
something like a cockroach this marked a
first for the season Doctor Who had
previously discovered everything from
condoms to sex toys inside the female
reproductive organs it's yet unclear how
The Cucaracha was reportedly who was
reportedly dead before he removed it as
a dead cockroach managed to end up down
under however the organ exterminator
site states that cockroaches tend to
prefer
dark moist places to hide and breed and
they can flatten their bodies to fit
into narrow areas
I just feel like that last part the New
York Post did not have to put in that
they preferred dark moist places no it
was definitely intense is the story over
or can I comment please comment I mean
talk about giving women another thing to
worry about like no but it's also crazy
like cockroaches don't die yeah I know
how did they die how did it die
cockroaches can survive a nuclear bomb
that's what we've been told yeah I mean
we don't know because no but isn't it
crazy that we all know that why we all
know that I don't know I feel like
that's like one of those things yeah and
like is it even true they also say that
cockroaches were like alive during like
dinosaur years were they oh yeah
cockroaches are they're like crocodiles
they will outlive us all cockroaches
crocodiles crocodiles alligators are
like I don't know if it's what's the
difference between crocodile and now
amazing question I have no idea I think
it's based on where you live alligators
are they won't call them dinosaurs but
they're dinosaurs what they've been
around Forever Wait I didn't know that
yeah isn't that crazy they've been
around since the day of the dinosaur yes
fact
that I like don't believe dinosaurs were
real
I mean is that like a hot take it's just
a dumb take oh is it okay we have the
bones no I know but like they could have
like faked it all the bones I just
refused to believe there was a time
where like literally the biggest animal
like three times the size of an elephant
which is current what's the biggest
animal right now an elephant a whale
yeah so dinosaur was as big as like a
yeah a great white think about how big
these sea animals are yeah I guess and
don't put me down this rabbit hole no I
know because I'm just saying we have not
even begun to scratch the surface of
exploring the Seas yeah no you're right
and what could be in those Seas could be
like a freaking animal the size of the
Empire State Building that's who knows
that's true who knows what was the story
oh the Cockroach the Cockroach I mean I
feel like I've heard stories even people
I know who've gotten like you know
tampons stuck in their vagina he said
sex toys condoms I've heard that I was
really not when the headline was
gynecologist reveals craziest thing he's
found I was not expecting it to be a
cockroach and now it just I feel like we
live in New York there's so many
cockroaches I have to really I have to
have my leg Stone shot where was she
where is she from oh he was from
Honduras and she was a patient who came
in from like a really rural part of the
country makes me sad because she was
probably like sleeping with cockroaches
no she was probably really uncomfortable
for if he died in there like no I'm
saying it was in order for a cockroach
to get up your nether regions you need
to be
infested yeah right which is sad it's
actually a sad story it's a very sad
story I'm glad she got the help she
needed yeah me too and I hope he didn't
lay any eggs
oh I didn't even think about that they
said dark moist areas is where
cockroaches like to lay eggs oh my God
terrible ugh yeah terrible story also
like are there why aren't there more
female gynecologists I feel like there
are a ton there are like I would say are
there more than men I don't know if
statistically but I have to imagine that
more than half of gynecologists are
women it just makes more sense you'd
think that they'd know more about their
own nether regions you know what you
could read in a book I definitely think
you know men and women can both do equal
things but like when I'm picking a
gynecologist like I'm picking a woman
I'm actively avoiding men my
gynecologist is a woman and the whole
practice is women so it's like she's out
I okay I'll see one of the other women
make sense to me uh excuse me your uncle
is a gynecologist correct and he's a
great didn't he deliver you no
definitely not I guess that would be
weird like very weird for him to be like
in your mom's yeah that would be very
weird yeah I'm just saying I wonder how
that goes when you have a gynecologist
and family did did Uncle Jeffrey deliver
any of your
cousins babies I don't think so
because I guess it's like a little
personal I think so maybe I'll have to
have Uncle Jeffrey on the podcast to ask
him yeah we could yeah you could
cool yeah
um what were you about to say no nothing
male gynecologists no I was just saying
that like I think it's like
it's a little weird I definitely think
it's a suspicious Choice yeah for sure a
little weird if you could become any I
feel like I keep making the stories and
being like if you could be in any band
if I could be any kind of doctor yeah
what kind of doctor would you want to be
huh am I financially motivated or am I
you're all things motivated all things
motivated take into account money
everything
hmm kind of doctor
I like the idea of like a really really
high profile surgeon
that does a lot of pressure I know but
you not only make a lot of money but you
also like save lives like how cool is it
sometimes
yeah well I would have a hundred percent
success rate oh okay in this fantasy
land okay I would I would make it I
would make sure of it yeah I would have
my own jingle like I feel like kind of a
low pressure doctor job is like a
dermatologist I feel like nobody dies on
the Dermatology table you know
that's true but dermatologists are also
you know if you're like a cosmetic
dermatologist and you do like botox you
make a lot of money no I'm not saying
that I'm just like I kind of think of
them as like
dentists and like and like Joe Biden
well okay let's talk you upset a lot of
people on the show on Friday I did yes
there were two things you said and one
of them I actually agree with people the
first thing you said was you weren't
giving nearly enough hype to LSU it was
like such a big deal they won like a lot
of people were interested in got it so
let's start there yeah go LSU LSU Tigers
Shaquille O'Neal love Shaq love human to
LSU Kim McKay who also was the is the
coach yeah she also went viral so
awesome we both were wrong in saying
that everyone was only tuning in for
Caitlin Clark no no
sorry I did not realize that that was
the gripe
everyone was only tuning in for Caitlyn
Clark
go LSU for sure statistically unless you
guys don't like statistics if it was a
non-cateland Clark
National Championship it would not have
broken these records she was the one who
went viral on Tick Tock she was the one
who dropped back to back 40 point games
she was the one who had like the is
having like the greatest career in the
history of women's college basketball
people tuned in for Caitlin Clark that
said go LSU so you stand by what you
said it's a it there's nothing to stand
by it's statistics and then the other
thing people were a little miffed by was
you saying one that dentists aren't real
doctors and I think people they're not
and I love them no I think people
probably misunderstood what you said
like you're still a doctor of dentistry
but it's like if you're on a plane and
you need a doctor the dentist isn't
standing up and saving any lives well
that's exactly right right and then
people were also upset that you said a
PhD is not a real doctor and those
people need to get a grip
because you can't be a doctor of math
that's exactly you can't be a doctor of
math yeah and also Save a Life they just
needed it just needs to be a different
word I agree having a doctorate in
something when somebody says I need a
doctor you can't do that person's
not gonna do anything it's a huge
accomplishment I don't know why it's the
same word
yeah you're not my name scaler you're
not an MD and you know Dr Drake ramore
are both doctors
that was good it's weird it's weird it
just is misleading so you're just making
enemies left and right every time you
come on the toast how does that feel
good good keep talking about me thank
you so much for being here I love
podcasting with you and this was our
last show of the week hope everybody uh
got through the week okay without the
toast but we're back and we're back on
Monday so we love you dearly thank you
so much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so if you're watching this on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up and let us know
what you think about this new setup
hopefully you like it I don't know what
it looks like yet we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so on Spotify
listen podcast review about a beautiful
setting and wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have an amazing weekend
we'll see you on Monday happy Good
Friday and Easter oh oh my God I'm
so like self-involved as a Jew happy
Good Friday he has risen and happy
Easter wishing love and light and I
think it's also Ramadan it is yes it's
kind of like I'm happy Ramadan it's a
big month
for all the religions I'm just gonna say
if it's not Ramadan but I think it's
coming up because I saw on my Google
Calendar
it said I'd
so Wishing Well Wishing Well to everyone
yes Happy Everything have a great
weekend and we'll see you on Monday bye